well thank you all very much uh and I'm
delighted to be here
some of you may remember
uh years ago
when we were expanding it oh I was the
one in the United States Senate was
pushing the hardest
to expand NATO for membership for many
of you sitting around this table
and uh the irony is
that uh
one of the last conversations I had with
the
our friend in Russia
was uh
I said you keep asking for the
finalization of NATO
you're going to get the natoization of
Finland
well it happened
not only are we as strong as well we're
stronger
and uh
I say to my fellow presidents that I'm
honored to be with you here
and uh so many strong NATO allies and uh
the Secretary General who I think has
done an incredible job an incredible job
for a long time I rely on his judgment a
great deal
you know the B9 was founded in 2015
after Russia attempted annexation of
Crimea
and today as we approach the uh one year
anniversary of Russia's further Invasion
it's even more important we continue to
stand together
and I think this is proof of this how
strongly we feel
that's why I wanted to meet all of you
in person here today as NATO's Eastern
flank you're in the front lines of our
Collective defense
and you know better than anyone what's
at stake in this conflict not just for
Ukraine but for the freedom of
democracies throughout Europe and around
the world
you know when that's what president
zielinski and I spoke about when I was
in Kiev two days ago
and uh
the leaders around this table have
repeatedly stepped up to reaffirm our
shared commitment to all these values
we provided critical security assistance
Ukraine and critical support to
literally millions of refugees
we've helped ensure ukrainians can
access basic services and together we'll
continue our enduring support for
Ukraine as they defend their freedom
over the past year with your countries
with country on this table providing
Collective leadership we've also
strengthened NATO
commitment of the United States to Nato
and I've said it to you many times I'll
say it again is absolutely
clear Article 5 is a sacred commitment
the United States has made we will
defend literally every inch of NATO
every inch of NATO
and is this an important moment
I look forward to the discussion the
next steps we can take together
and to keep our alliance strong
and to further deter aggression
because what literally is at stake is
not just Ukraine
it's freedom the idea that over a
hundred thousand forces would invade
another country after War since World
War II nothing like that has happened
things have changed radically we have to
we have to make sure we change them back
so thank you all very much for allowing
me to be with you and I look forward to
our private discussions